hi I'm Margaret young and I was taking
part in the human rights Global Agenda
Council for the last two days and like
all the other Agenda councils we were
discussing a new model and our
particular new model had to do with the
issue of human rights and business so
very recently the united nations adopted
a new framework on the topic of human
rights in business and the framework was
intended to clarify what the
responsibilities of companies are for
human rights and what the
responsibilities of states are for human
rights so to give you an example in the
world where international human rights
law was framed it was actually developed
in a post World War two ERA and so the
world is very much focused on States as
being the potential violators of human
rights as well as States as being the
potential greatest defenders of Human
Rights but recently then with the
expansion of the multinational you would
have multinationals that we go all over
the world and actually in many
situations have more power than then a
state to affect and realize human rights
so at the time they developed a blurring
of the concept of what the
responsibility was of the company I mean
does a company in a local area where the
government is not present do they have
the responsibility to build a hospital
or to build a road there are times when
companies possess essential drugs or
medicines that governments can't afford
for the population so we had for many
years this outstanding question of what
the responsibilities of companies were
and finally it was taken on by Professor
John Ruggie who was the United Nations
Special Representative on the topic of
human rights in business and over a
six-year process he developed this
framework which which managed to obtain
a lot of consensus around the idea of
companies with the basic duty to respect
human rights so that is to take all
necessary measures to avoid infringing
the rights of human beings not just in
their their employment situations so
respecting the rights of workers but
also when they purchase land to to
respect the rights of those land holders
and to make sure they're resettled
properly as well as in the marketing
distribution and other practices so he
defined that scope as being the
responsibility of companies and then
there was a corresponding responsibility
of governments as well to take measures
to protect people from corporate abuses
so to pass the right laws into a
enforced laws against companies abusing
human rights and so with this framework
it went to the United Nations and was it
received unanimous endorsement of the
United Nations which is which is very
unusual in the UN Human Rights Council
and then we as a group decided to take
this forward and action it because at
the moment it still sits within that UN
space which is very it is quite isolated
not many companies know about this so
our group decided how will we action
this and raise awareness amongst
business CEOs when they go to Davos as
well as action it within States to let
them know their obligations in terms of
formulating the right policies and
passing the road right laws in this area
as well as how do we action it in civil
society so that the media conveys the
issue is correctly that the NGOs are
active around the right issues so we get
really that entire global model pushing
for the adoption of this of this very
new framework in the human rights in
business space so that's what our global
agenda council is looking forward to
taking forward not only in the Davos
space but also will remain active
afterwards to try to take it forward
within the individual company space and
with industry sectors going forward